Hello, well, okay, ignore that, the server's gone anyway,
so...
That's for the...
It's not really a leak when the server's gone, so that was
for the bowers.
Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Sorry we had to start a bit late.
Apparently, the concert also started late, so then I had to
start late as well.
And then my schedule is dictated by others.
But let me pull everything up real quick.
Oh my god, I already forgot which one was the controller.
Oh, what is the...
What the fuck is the controller thing called?
Okay, VTuber controller program.
There we go.
What is it called?
Okay, nah, I need to write this.
I need to keep writing this.
I keep forgetting what it's called.
Narupad.
There we go.
Oh, oh, my marriage...
Guys, I'm sorry.
I just came back from walking through and getting water.
So for those who watched, the Vexpo concert.
Do you guys enjoy it?
For those who didn't watch the Vexpo concert, do not worry
about the FOMO because, oh my God, I gave you food.
I fed you before you stream.
No.
I actually fed him before I started streaming, too.
Like, I made sure, and he's still the man anymore.
He's so spoiled.
Anyway, nobody's thinking of a super chat.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Joki.
Hope you're doing well.
Hope would love to be able to go to one of your concerts one
day.
Never been overseas before.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you're able to go to one of my concerts one day, too.
I'm so happy for all the people who love the concert.
For those who are experiencing FOMO right now.
Do not worry.
The concert will be uploaded onto our channels.
I don't know if, do we once like her?
Okay, do you want me to spoil you guys a set list for those
who are, or you guys want to be surprised?
Solid.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Just wanted to say amazing concert, Doki.
Always love your duets with Duberts.
Can't wait for the directors cut.
super chat thank you thank you we haven't really do we not
haven't really talked about like um like if the songs we
should separate the songs we uploaded on which channel and
stuff like that um i did i paid for um almost everything i
paid out of my own pocket uh so uh like it wasn't funded by
anybody or like it wasn't funded by like an outside source i
personally paid paid for the the motion capture, the
animations, almost all the mixing, such as Puppy Pu, which
was mixed by Duby's mixer, and so all, and also, like, so
all of it was paid for by me, but yes, for the set list, it
was, we started off with We Will Rock You.
We wanted to do, like, half European set list there, so we
started off with We Will Rock You, and then I, my solo, was
Iro-Papa, and then Doobie's solo was Popipo, and then the
last two duets was Brain Rot and Baby.
So that was the entire set list.
So I will say Iro-Papa was one of the hardest songs I've
ever recorded because it was all in, not just in Dutch, but
it was like in Dutch and German.
For those who don't know, I have a Dutch manager, and he was
very anal about my pronunciation of all the Dutch words that
I had to sing in Europapa, because their language is like,
ha, ha, ha, he hated the way I pronounce, welcome in Europa,
but I feel like, don't try, because I say try, and so I'm
like, Welcome in Europa, blanket to do try, like that.
I'm supposed to pronounce it like, do try.
But I keep saying do try, because it was so hard to be...
Ha!
When I'm singing, when I'm singing.
He said, this is not the Dutch way.
He was just like, this does not sound Dutch enough.
Do it again, do it again.
I'm like, I don't want to do it again.
Please, I've been trying to sing this one line for 20
minutes.
He's like, this is not good enough.
Sing it again.
I'm like, oh.
So, and then after I finished recording it, he was just
like, I'm not happy with how you pronounce this.
It's like, I'm like, I'm like, I was like, bro.
I'm not recording, I'm recording.
Please, I spent three days trying to record this.
Yes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That was absolutely incredible in person, Doki.
Thank you for all your effort.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He was like, I'm not happy with how you pronounce welcome in
your note, the bye video to the do try.
He's like, he's like, this is the one line I'm not happy
about.
all of that and then he's like i let my mom listen to it and
she said that it was like she could understand it but he was
just like but it just doesn't sound right and he was just
like but it's just it just doesn't ah it bones why aren't
why can't you pronounce these Dutch words perfectly
patch thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
welcome to Europa Canada now the ritual about your ass and
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you apparently
his mom thought I did pretty decent because she was like
saying yeah I can understand her there's an accent I can
understand her but even then he was he will never be happy
with my Dutch pronunciation he will never be happy about it
he even said like notes to my mixer being like um During
this take, this was the one that she pronounces the most
accurate Dutch.
Like she literally, because I sent him my Dutch recordings
to have him like listen through it, have him listen through
the Euro Papa just to make sure like I actually sound like
legible.
Um, and he was like, and then he like sent notes to the
mixer himself about like how, yeah, in take one, uh, this is
the one where she pronounces the Dutch the best.
And he's like, don't use this take because this does not
sound Dutch enough.
sound like a Dutch language.
Or like, this does not sound like she's saying Dutch at all.
So don't use this thing, but use this take instead.
Or like, these are the takes that I feel sound the most
Dutch.
So, so your papa was one of the hardest songs I've ever
recorded.
I also had to do it like, I had to do it by like, also, it
might be clean.
Thank you for the red.
Thank you.
You had a great stream.
gosh it was like i said i've never sang in dutch before so
i've never sang in the dutch language before so it was
definitely very very difficult but i hope it was okay i did
tell silent i was really like there's i was like there can't
be that many dutch people in the audience silent there's
like they won't notice but he's like but i'll notice i will
notice i was like It's like, it's a European convention.
It's like, they can't all be Dutch.
They can't all understand the Dutch language.
At least I made the attempt, you know.
And he's like, but I will know.
I will know that you're singing it wrong.
Nobody's thinking about the gifted chip.
Thank you.
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
This was his way of getting back to you for all the deadlush
and that again.
You made him grow through.
Riku, the super chat.
Thank you.
But yes, I will be uploading the full director's cuts
because we're going to be fixing it up a bit.
Okay, so it was done.
The concert was done by four different teams.
Like four different teams.
So Kanaru did We Will Rock You.
Mick did...
brain rot and Earpapa.
We had some motion capture done in LA.
And then also we had the baby and Po-Pipo done by the people
who did my Anime Expo birthday concert.
it was done by four different teams.
A collaborative work with four different teams.
And I will be uploading a special uh choreo videos of i
think it's a special choreo videos of uropapa baby and uh
popipo um i'm the members so we actually have like a so
it'll be like a center and you'll see all the choreo of
everything especially for your uropapa half of that was
actually motion captured so uropapa was half animated and
half motion captured and we choreoed the entire uropapa a
song based off of the live performance by Yoast Klein.
So, like, you know, the live Eurovision version that Yoast
Klein did with a dance and everything.
That was fully motion captured.
And I have the motion capture video of it, and I'll be
uploading that in members in the future.
So I just need to, like, swap the song because it was motion
captured via the original Yoast Klein song.
I can't really, I don't, maybe I can show it.
Let me see if I can have, I find the file.
But it's like, like I said, the audio is from the Yoast Clan
original version, so I have to swap the audio for it.
But because like Yoast, the Yoast Papa was fully actually
choreoed and motion captured.
I do want to like, you know, I don't want to like waste it,
you know, because we only took half of it for the animated
video.
Used half of it.
But like huge shout out to the entire team because it took
them a month and a half to get all of this done.
separated to four different teams.
So each person has like one song or two.
So it took like, it was basically a month and a half project
for four different.
Like that was like separated between four different teams.
Huge shout out to Mick because he took on two songs all by
himself.
And fully and like not fully, so not full animate, but like,
oh yeah, and Brainwad.
Sorry, Brainwad.
I will also post in members as well.
So I have like full choreos, Brainwad, Po-Pipo, Euro Papa.
and baby so i'll be posting all that it'll be like a no no
like different camera angles it was just a center shot of
you seeing the entire core of everything and i think i'll be
really pretty excited i think that'll be pretty cool behind
the scenes thing let's look at um man he showed i was i love
working with uh mick uh because he's very talented um
apparently he was also there watching watching it too um he
watched his own like performance like the uh his uh um you
know being debuted at Vexpo and everything.
So yeah, shout out for him.
I love working with that guy.
Very talented individual, very talented Alan Mader too.
The fact that he did all of that by himself.
In such a tight schedule as well.
Incredible work.
But yeah, I'll show you guys more behind the scenes of
everything.
Because I'll show it at a different stream.
I don't want to show it here.
I'll show it tomorrow because I need to compile.
Like I don't have everything down.
like i was saying i'm a mess right now i have so many stuff
going on behind the scenes at the moment especially with a
tournament next week um and everything with the apex
tournament i still need to like i need to like fucking get
that sorted out uh well oh yeah let me see i think i can i
think i can grab oh my gosh that i don't know why that is
like i'm like i'm like you had food you already had food all
right let me say i could find it i'm gonna see uh all right
it's loading on discord so i don't know which one what what
give him a bone give him a treat i can't he's gonna keep
coming back if i don't give him ah he i he trained me
he went straight to the tree corner he fucking knows oh my
god he fucking know oh shit i not talk about the apex
tournament uh no i didn't i talk no i talked about it here
already i about it in public public stream i remember um all
right here we go let me see i'm gonna mute the audio of it
let me double check though welcome in europa black future
daughter euro papa euro papa sorry that song is like stuck
in my head a lot all right there you go okay i'll whoa i
closed up all my tabs i double clicked A friendly fire!
My tabs!
Oh my god, my 50 tabs!
Oh no!
Alright, there we go.
I got it.
Alright.
I don't want to...
Oh, whatever.
Yo's clan.
I'll let you take the ad revenue off of this.
I'm just like, I don't know if like how much ad, I don't
know how bad it's gonna be, but uh, Yo Sklad, you can take
the ad revenue.
So, uh, let's see.
All right, here you go.
So here's like the choreo for, I'll show a little bit of it.
I'll skim through it too.
I don't keep Yeah, it's too pose Where is it?
Yeah So some of this you don't see in the actual Animation
Just because we did It was just we fully choreoed Motion
captured Euro Papa Only because like just in case Just in
case you know So like the animator could like pick whichever
part they want to do To put in the animation So it's like
This would be posted in like in the membership like the full
thing But like this is my favorite part because I love this
part.
Which one?
No, not this one This part.
Yeah So it's very so Hey
So it's very so so Similar to this is very similar to the
original Eurovision performance That Yos Klan performed This
is using Wow, Doki This is using so I wanted it to be like
Like similar to like the original Yos Klan Eurovision
performance too So this part, this part You guys remember
from the Eurovision Hey Euro
I'll swap the audio with the original like what I recorded
welcome to y'all y'all in
So I'll be posting all, oh sorry, I'm so sorry because that
that I won't be purchasing this version of it but oh wait
actually yeah I would sorry the mouse thing that's gonna be
there unfortunately unfortunately the mouse is gonna be
there because that was what we were sent uh we were sent for
like previews of like how the preview would look like so i
don't unfortunately there's going to be a cursor for that
particular video it's gonna be right there in the center so
i'm sorry it's baked into the preview um but yes it'll be
your papa brain rot bo people and baby I do have the choreos
and motion capture of that recorded.
So I will post that in the members.
So that'll be a member exclusive.
The other, all the other stuff, like the songs and stuff,
that will be public as well.
I have to talk to Duby, like if she wants to post pop people
on her channel and everything.
We will be swapping the model of the Duby model with her
Vocaloid Duby model because that was a little oopsie on my
part because I didn't realize she sent me her Vocaloid
version.
By the time it was like too late to swap the models.
So on the director's cut, we will be using her Vocaloid
model for Popipo because that's like what she originally
wanted.
And yeah.
I hope you guys, for those who watched it, I can give you
guys a little preview of EuroPapa so that you won't be like,
FOMO!
I'll give you guys, let me see.
I haven't, I need to download.
Like I said, I have a lot of stuff I need to download too.
Uh, so that was my issue if I haven't downloaded a lot of
stuff for it.
So, uh, all right.
Let's see.
Whoops.
Now I accidentally downloaded Brain Rot and Euro Papa.
I just want to download.
Uh, Euro Papa.
Euro Papa.
But I know Mick said that.
He wants to touch it up a little bit more.
So, like I said, it is going to have a little director's cut
because he wanted to, because, you know, he had to animate
the whole thing within the very strict deadline.
And he had to do two videos.
So, because of it, we're going to have the anime, like Brain
Ra and Europapa might have a refined version just in case,
like if he wants to touch it up more or change some things
or fix it a little bit more.
But that's on the animator.
Honestly, amazing work that he's done, even with such a
tight deadline.
I think it looks amazing, but I'll show you guys.
Europe!
Let's come together!
I'll show you guys a little bit of it.
My manager was not happy about those recordings.
by the way, specifically that part.
Yeah,
so that's a little preview.
A little preview, your old papa.
Um, yeah, for guys who don't know, rapping in Dutch is
surprisingly very, very hard.
So that's all you guys get until, uh, until, uh, well, I
mean, you can watch if you guys bought the streaming ticket
for Bexpo, you can watch it right now.
Um, but yes, I'll have directors cut later on, upload it.
I might have Europopapa upload it as, uh, its own video, uh,
just because of, all the effort that's put into it um so
your papa would definitely be its own video uploaded for
sure um and i hope the dutch won't be the the dutch people
won't be too mad at my pronunciation after it's like out in
the public i hope i hope i don't get criticized too hard
about my dutch pronunciation
done the vexbo stuff is done that one was stressing me out a
lot because we got i think like everything we got all the
files of everything from everybody like i think two days ago
and that was a week past the deadline of when we were
supposed to had in our files so so that one was very it was
very stressful because like we got everything like all the
the animators from everyone uh two days ago and we were
supposed to hand it all in to vexbo a week ago and the week
ago was the extended deadline because two weeks ago was the
first deadline and then we asked for an extension so they're
like okay you can we uh we'll give you another week and then
we're like okay we might need a little bit more because when
we have half the songs done they're like okay we'll give you
like as long as it's like you know like because we had like
we're like we need a little bit more time to finish cooking
everything up um so we're very very thankful that vexbo was
very accommodating um was very accommodating with uh letting
us submit our stuff uh later uh just like i because like i
said like we got everything everything all the files not
just like some people submitted early but we we want to have
handed in all the files like two days ago and they were able
to make sure you know uh the tech pre like they were able to
tech support all of it just in time for the actual concert
itself so thank god for that uh i don't know i know i said i
will finish the game today but i might not actually because
i'm i woke up on the wrong side of bed today so i'm a little
i'm a little tired and also like i had a lot of worked I had
a lot of work stuff to do yesterday and I have a lot of work
stuff to do today as well um so I might not be able to do a
long stream because I was thinking I was just like I just go
ahead and just fit go all the way to the end but honestly
right now my mental right now my mindset I'm a little tired
so I mean you can tell I'm literally in my pajamas I'm I'm
sort of I'm a little overworked at the moment from
everything.
Kuka, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
So I'm not like feeling the greatest at the moment.
You know, like, you know, we had a great Vexpo concert.
We had a great Vexpo concert and, you know, the reception
for that was amazing.
But I'm just like, I think I just woke up on the wrong side
of bed today.
that part is over the vexbo concert stuff is over i still oh
my gosh i just remember i have a meeting greet i'm it just
hit me okay it just hit me i have a meeting greet at two in
the morning okay today so i got so so i gotta prepare myself
i gotta mentally prepare myself for that because it's two in
the morning and uh time soon's a so yeah i have to have to
reset myself for uh reset myself for it oh my god why no no
no oh he's getting like more and more vocal every day every
you know like he doesn't do that off stream by the way it's
always on stream he doesn't do that off stream he knows like
whenever i he's like who are you talking to like you know
he's like feeding time.
Nobody.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey.
No.
Go.
He's too smart.
He doesn't do this off stream.
I swear to God.
He like ignores me all the time off stream.
But then whenever I stream, he just knows.
He's like, this is where I can get it.
This is where I can take advantage of her situation.
What else?
Is there anything else I want to talk about?
I think that's really it.
Is there anything on Doki News Network?
I've been so all over the place.
I don't even know there's anything in Doki News Network that
I missed out on.
Well, I guess like on Doki News Network, the baby fight
somewhere was another baby fight club ring that got broken.
That got uncovered.
And I was like, another one?
Oh, it's for those who don't know.
Apparently, Recently, parents are suing a Texas daycare for
over a million dollars for running a fight club for
toddlers.
So it was like basically a teacher was encouraging their son
to fight another four-year-old son.
So there was like, and like, yeah, so security photo footage
show that.
So like a second baby fight club has surfaced.
No, my entertainment, how could they take that down?
It was starting to get so good.
Yeah, who the fuck snitched on my baby fight club?
Who was it?
That was my favorite channel.
I had a million dollars on the line for my baby.
They broke the first rule.
Never talk about baby fight club.
Um, let me adjust the sound settings real quick.
Um, my pay-per-view.
Doki News Network is not reputable news.
Who said that?
Oh, Steve, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It is fact checked by Mr. Elon Musk himself.
If there's no community note, it's real.
Our sources, if there's no community note on our sources
then it's real lies lies on this team your number one news
your number one source for news uh lali thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you another one already are gonna
find out there's actually an underground baby fight world
champ honestly i will not be surprised if that actually
exists that seems like the that seems very likely not gonna
lie like people are very very bored and i will not be
surprised if there was an underground baby fight world
championship that you just gotta know someone to get access
to you just gotta know know someone who knows someone um
let's see oops power surge on the us okay let me uh plug in
my plug there you go just plugging in my controller.
I just say my controller has not enough power.
What the fuck?
I don't think that's true.
2K, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the nice content.
I would love to...
I couldn't hear the reception of...
I wish I could, like...
I wish I could hear how people reacted to Euro Papa.
Because I want to know who is there.
I know some people that... I don't know anyone who's in chat
right now was at the concert um because i think the concert
i don't know the concert just end i'm pretty sure the
concert just ended or something uh go out they give us a
super chat thank you thank you my real girlfriend called me
baby so i'm gonna join the fight club now the crowd went
mental i think like nobody expected your old papa like
because it's in fucking dutch and dokey doesn't sing in
dutch like he's like who's crazy enough to rap the entire
dutch language who's great i'm crazy enough me I'm I'm crazy
enough to do it I have to rap fucking Dutch as someone who
doesn't even speak Dutch what no no go go but yeah uh I even
to be fair my manager tried to stop me because I was papa
he's like what's your set list i was like blah blah and i
was like and he's like euro papa and he's like i was like
yeah i want to do it i think it's gonna go crazy if you're
gonna love it because it's a european convention and euro
papa is literally like like one of the european songs and
then he was like don't do it like he tried to stop me he's
like i don't think you should do it it's a very hard song
and i don't know you can do it it's like i was like i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna prove you wrong
I'm just like, I'm, I'm gonna prove you wrong.
I can do it.
I, he didn't, he didn't believe it.
He still doesn't believe.
He's like, he's like, are you sure?
Are you sure?
We're gonna have to do like lessons and you have to be in
college so I could teach you how to, and then he actually
helped me a lot.
He recorded like the Dutch lyrics, like, and repeated it
very slowly for me in recording so I could like repeat after
him.
He did line by line too.
So he repeated line by line for me.
And I just like use that as my source to be for like Dutch
pronunciation because obviously like the singing, like when
I listened to the original recording, they're singing it
really fast.
So then he repeated the entire, all the lyrics over me line
by line.
So I could, and I just kept repeating it over and over again
until it was stuck in my head.
Do you okay, thank you for the super chat?
Thank you, thank you.
Oh man, I wish, I wish, I don't know if silent recorded the
crowd reaction, but I would, I wish I could see it.
I wish I could see the crowd reaction, especially like when
I was like, I don't care who you are, and then the beat
drops.
It's like, that's the most exciting part.
especially whenever goes hey and um everyone says euro pop
pop pop pop pop pop pop pop yeah like hey oh i'm sorry i i i
really like euro pop pop too i really like the song i don't
know the beat is very catchy for me um so that's why it's
like it was um it was like the first thing i the first song
I thought of doing when I was asked to do Vexpo opening
concert and it's such a catchy song it's been stuck in my
head for a while now ever since I first listened to it in
the original Eurovision version so I was super happy to be
able to cover it and I hope I did it justice I know I'm
focusing so much on Euro Papa but it's honestly like my in
the entire set list I feel proud song uh the most my most
proud song i did for the concert um just because of how hard
it was and how uh much my manager criticized me criticized
my pronunciation
um but hey people loved it so people still loved it
So I'm happy that a lot of people enjoyed the concert.
Silent in the back.
That's what Matt exactly is.
I was just like, how many people are going to be touching
the audience, silent, as long as they think, as long as it's
like vaguely similar.
I was like, they're not going to know, they're not going to
realize I mispronounced it.
He's like, I'll know, I'll know though, Toki.
I was like, I was like, the entire audience cannot be fully
Dutch silent.
It's a European convention.
There's people from all over Europe.
He's like, but I'm from, I will know.
Yeah.
It'll know.
So.
So, yeah, looking forward to the official upload for the
Bexpo concert.
Anyway, I think that's all of it.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, she pronounced the words wrong.
Okay, and exactly.
Sounds good enough.
All right, all right, let's play Onimusha.
Like I said, it's not going to be, I'm going to change the
stream time.
title to in it right now um just so you guys know I'm not
gonna be finishing the game today like I said I'm not I'm
not not feeling it today I guess like I have my head not in
my head sorry we do not finish the game today like I'm just
feeling a little down you know that's why I do love
streaming because streaming always makes me happier um in
general and but like today I'm just feeling so I don't want
to push myself too hard.
I just woke up on the wrong side of bed today.
But, you know, you guys always cheer me up, and that's why I
love streaming for you guys.
I just know that, like, I don't think I can do a very long
stream today, also because I know I've worked stuff.
I have work stuff, a lot of work stuff to do that to catch
up, not still catch up on, but just a lot of planning and
things I have to do for the next week.
But streaming for you guys always makes me feel a lot
better.
I love hanging out with all of you guys a lot.
And yeah, I'm so happy for that.
People enjoyed the concert.
Like I said, it's a huge bird and huge relief off my
shoulders.
Like my matcha and I were so stressed out about it.
Like we had some, we like had some arguments with each other
and a call several times regarding the Vexpo concert because
of all the stuff that was going on.
Like all the stuff that we had to juggle about it and
everything and all the mixing and stuff that we had to do
for the, like I said, huge shout out to team.
like i always have ashwin music team doing all my mixing and
stuff um and they all did all like the fact that they were
able to do it all within a month and a half deadline and
everything really shout out to them um and stuff like we got
the songs done like literally like this week by the way the
songs were fully done like uh on sunday i think uh and then
we handed it all for like uh
uh so like oh my gosh like they they everybody worked so
hard and came in clutch with everything and i really
appreciate that all like the team and everything for getting
all of it done nobody singing the super chat thank you thank
you no worries jokey paste yourself and take breaks when
need it oh yeah i do have like a i can show you guys later
like on tomorrow's stream the behind the scenes of some of
the songs it was so funny because it was my bad so um i'm
like the one the the animators that did Yoropapa and Rain
Rot this is like their first I'm like I think I was like
their first client ever they're very talented animator in
general and I commissioned them before for the Doki Doki
Rewind Time Doki Doki Rewind Time little opening thing that
was shown with writing the Apex segment so I was like their
first person never commissioned them and um and so like you
know there's like a learning process for them since I was
their first client and so and then they did the music video
too and um hey no no no no no anyway um anyway it's really
funny because um there's so many things going on and so I
didn't didn't realize for brain rot i forgot to give them
the lyric split um because obviously they had to animate um
while like without hearing this hearing the version of dubie
and i but so they were just animating based off the original
song and i didn't realize because i sent them a lot of files
of like here's all the models here's all the 3d models
here's all the extra um assets that i've had made for
various other 3d projects and everything i sent so many
files and then i realized I never sent them the lyric split
of brain rot So I have a version I'll show you guys tomorrow
I have a version of brain rot Where it's me dancing And then
Duby's voice coming out of my mouth I'm so sorry And they
had to get that fixed Within 24 hours Because like it was
like We just had one more day left So I was like oh my god
did not send you the lyrics split why why i was just like
wait what happened and there i was like oh i didn't i did it
i'm so sorry because like like i said i told him i was like
look if if ask for the lyric split next time you feel like
it's weird that you know since i was like their first client
so like they don't know that there's usually a lyric split
being given on who's like you don't don't you don't have to
guess who's gonna sing so he was actually trying to figure
guess who was singing what line himself and then i was like
don't don't worry like that was my mistake usually the
client will give you a lyric split so you don't have to
guess on who's performing what like so he had to swap like
the models and stuff within 24 hours um and redo the lip
syncing and every like read not all of it but it was like it
was just like not even half of it it was just like one
fourth of it was just um because it's a short song anyways
it was like one fourth of it like maybe like three to four
like i think like four four scenes i think where it was like
obviously i should be singing like i was singing dubby's
part dubby was singing my part and it was like yeah so i
have to um so it was like you see like me dancing and it was
just me dancing and it is dubie's voice coming out of my
mouth and then dubie dancing and then my voice coming out of
her mouth and i'm like oh no i'm so sorry so i'll show that
it's pretty funny but i'm just like wait a minute this is
this is wait a minute something's off here
Super Chat thinking, thank you.
Now, the anime was secretly just a guy who came in the
stream one time drunk and Super Chat thinking you were a
dubie.
So I'll show you guys that tomorrow, chat.
Anyway, a huge shout out to Dubie for putting up with my
crazy schemes.
Like I said, it could have just been like normal, like 2D
performance where we're just on the screen just seeing.
But the fact that she was willing to hop a lot on my crazy
ride I've been on my crazy ride Doing a 3D set list within a
month and a half And she was like, okay I thought this was
just gonna be 2D But okay So shout out to Dewey for Saying
yes And hearing me out And letting me do this crazy plan And
I'm glad everybody enjoyed it Otaku, thank you, thank you,
thank you I don't watch your stream that often, but I do
have a sense how genuine you are.
I hope you're so well.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I really appreciate it.
But yeah, like I said, I spent a lot of my own money for it.
Like, like, yeah, like, you know, I got paid to appear in
Bexpo, but, um, I spent more money on the opening concert
than, like, I think we can all tell.
I spent a lot more money on the opening concert than while I
was paid to appear, uh, at Bexpo, but I did all of that.
because I wanted to spoil the European dragoons that was
there.
Just because, like I said, you guys don't get a lot of
opportunities, especially concerts as well, especially 3D
concerts.
You guys don't have a lot of these types of opportunities to
see in person and experience it as well.
So this was my treat to the European dragoons, especially
those who have to wake up so early to watch my streams or
stay up really late to watch it.
um so i want to do something extra special to the european
dragoons uh and uh the european fans who are watching um
getting to experience like your own uh even though it was
just 20 minutes uh your very own like um like you know mini
set list uh from dubie and i so i hope you guys liked it and
um it was like uh you know i spent uh it came out of my own
pocket and everything and even my manager thought like my
manager already thought I was crazy uh my manager already
thought I was crazy for doing uh all of that and it was like
are you sure it's like yes yes I think people are gonna love
it I think people are gonna love it so much and then people
did yeah people really loved it and I'm really happy how how
good it came I'm really really happy um and uh yeah it was
And yeah, I'm glad the European Dragoons really enjoyed the
show.
That's all I wanted.
And I'm so happy that everyone had a great time.
All right.
That's enough.
That's enough about Vexpo.
Well, do let's continue.
Patch Doki left me in the poison swamps.
So let's run it back.
Apparently, I missed out on a weapon.
And I was told.
I was told that I missed out on a very important weapon
because I was not paying attention.
How do I get there, though?
I guess it's, like, back here.
Should I go up?
So it's not poison swamps just yet.
Oh, I hate the poison swamps so much.
Also, apparently, I just stopped at a very, very hard bot.
I am not in the right mood right now, dude.
I'm like, I woke up on the wrong side of bed.
I am not in the right mood.
I'm so out of it today.
Is it not here?
Oh, my God.
Where did it at?
Okay.
It's like some, oh, my God.
It's all the way back.
there oh my god all right let's see it so I can figure this
out okay it's apparently further back than I thought it was
let me go back yeah I was gonna say it would be easier to
teleport I was like oh it's all the way back there it's hit
so far it's oh I gotta hate the poison swamps I don't know,
I just...
I think I just feel like...
I feel like down and tired.
That's like, it's a combination, but like my eyes feel a
little heavy, too.
So it's like a combination of...
I know like streaming-wise, it usually helps me reset myself
too, so...
But I know I can't do a long stream.
I know like I can't force myself to...
I shouldn't force myself to do a really long stream.
Oh my god, where is it?
Where am I?
Where...
First off, where am I?
What is this?
Oh my god, which one is it?
Where am I?
Like, is that me?
Is this me?
No, no, that's not me.
Where am I?
Is it this?
Oh my god, where am I?
Where?
I actually don't okay cave one is this right oh my god
that's me right is that me that's me okay that's wait no uh
oh oh that's me that's oh my god there was a cave two there
was there was a i didn't know how to scroll down for cave
two all right what's over here no way oh my god this was the
whole problem anyway all right okay this one right no that's
the block gate where is it is it this oh my god where is it
where is the cave so good they made cave too i don't know
what to do with dad not gonna lie That's been, like, I don't
know, guys.
Maybe here?
It's here.
Cave 2.
Hey.
No.
Go.
Oh, my gosh.
I have to, like, all right, this way.
No, this is where I was.
This is cave 1.
Oh, I'm so confused.
No.
No, this is no.
This is K1.
Okay, it's here.
It's here.
Oh my god, where is it?
Where?
No, I just clapped my hands.
I did this.
Castle entrance, elevator.
God, where is it?
Not there?
I don't know.
It's so confusing.
I'm so lost.
Okay.
Castle entrance.
Okay, but which one?
Oh, this one.
It's right here.
Okay.
All right.
Gotta go now.
Hope you get feeling better.
Hopefully my fellow dragon said, cheer you up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nobody's don't worry.
You guys always cheer me up.
You guys always make me feel a lot better.
That's why I love streaming for you guys.
No matter what happens, like I know you guys are always
there for me.
I'm picking up.
I'm gonna pick you up.
I don't care.
Oh, you're gonna run away?
You're gonna run away?
Pick them up.
Oh, now you're not gonna say shit.
I see.
I gotta pick them up.
It's fucking right.
Alright.
He's on my lap now.
I think I can play with him on my...
On my arms.
Okay, not great.
But, we're gonna have to make do.
A broken bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Using Cantonese words here.
Maybe it worked again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Broken bond.
Thank you, thank.
I don't know why.
I think he sees the food.
He knows there's food.
there to here he knows there oh here's this one he knows
there's food um and he just wants it all and i was like you
can't eat it all because you gotta save the food for dinner
that's your dinner stupid dog you can't just eat it all
because after you eat it all you'll have nothing to eat
later
all right reading a lightning spear made by the owning deals
heavy uh health damage and produces many red souls was that
will that be useful though or is for like the oh for my oh
for this guy yes fuck that guy in particular I'll use it
specifically for that guy my fucking kryptonite yeah I was
gonna say what I feel like the shot earth shatter and uh
fire one it was already good enough
Oh, look at that.
Look at him.
Like a bitch.
Oh, now you're just gonna sleep in my arms?
Yeah, fucking right.
That's right.
Yeah, I'm talking about you.
He looked up at me.
He's like, what you say?
I was like, yeah, I'm talking about you, little bitch.
Alright, let's go up the elevator.
He literally looked at me, too, when I said that.
You stared up at me.
He tucked his head in my arms.
And after I called him, how he, like, looked at me.
Oh, you're quiet now, huh?
Yeah?
We're not going to say anything anymore?
Huh?
You're going to be a little bitch now?
Yeah, a little bitch?
Huh?
A little bitch boy?
That's right, that's you.
We're a little bitch boy.
you are.
Yeah, I'm fucking idiot.
Say anything in that tone.
You won't know.
You doesn't know what it means.
Am I supposed...
Oh, no.
Wait, where's...
Wait, where's the...
Where's the teleport?
Oh, there it is.
all right kate oh i have enough for enhancement oh for this
i don't know this is like worth it in
general uh abel thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you he's a little chud that's right you're a little chud
aren't you right oh he's tucking himself like between my
arms again
all right i think is all he wanted the thing is i don't know
i can't play like this i can't like play i can't like kill
people like this in this position that's the worst part
uh good luck playing yeah i can't react very pro i can't
react like this It's gonna be very hard.
Yeah.
I'm here to know, Dad.
I'm trying my best to play video games with you on me.
All right.
Is there anything here?
Where the fuck is the poison swamp, though?
Now!
That's awkward.
God damn it, it's Dad's fault.
It's like a dad's bug.
I was trying to do...
Okay.
Oh my god, I can't.
Oh my god.
I'm...
Oh fuck.
Oh, I'm trying to do a wield right now.
It's so hard.
Oh my god, it's so hard to play.
It is actually so hard to play right now.
I'm not okay.
Wait, oh shit, is that where the...
Can you...
Oh, man, where is it?
Oh, where is it?
No, it's not up here.
Oh, my God, I can't play in this condition!
That, oh, my God, he looked up at me.
He's like, what are you talking about?
He's like, looking at me, like, what are you talking about?
Oh, no.
He's actually looking at me right now.
It's like, what do you mean?
That's right, it's your fault.
That's your fault, little guy.
It's all your fault, you little guy, you little, little guy.
There you go.
He's like, but I'm having a great time.
Yep, I know you are.
Fuck, guys.
Let me try my best right now.
It's very, very difficult.
Alright, here we go.
Gosh shit.
Is this anywhere important?
Okay.
I don't know.
No, I'm putting him fucking down the moment I'm at the boss.
The moment I'm at any area where it seems like I need a
fight, He's not sitting here anymore.
I'm kicking them out.
It's very hard right now to play like this.
Can you stand?
No, I should prove no much for you.
Oh, God.
Let's hope there's nothing over here.
Okay, thank God there's nothing over here.
Alright, nice.
Anything back here?
Any secrets?
Okay.
Alright.
Oh.
Where is that glowing thing?
What do my eyes see?
Oh, there is.
Okay, there's something holding that up so I have to destroy
it later.
Wait, which way do I go?
There's two ways.
Oh my gosh, I hate having options.
Oh, it's over here.
Never mind.
Oh, come on.
Get out of here.
Alright.
We can grab this now, though.
I know a game you can play with that particular problem.
It's called Wolverine.
Look, I'm not that desperate, guys.
Guys, I'm not that desperate.
I have a lot of games I can play.
I still can't believe they spent $300 million on it.
That's fucking insane that that was a $300 million game.
I just feel bad for, like, for, like, the devs in general.
Can I grab everything here?
I don't know.
Like, at that point, it feels like a...
What's the word?
Okay.
Um, money laundering.
At that point, I want to know if they were money laundering
or some shit.
Like, how the fuck is it?
300 million.
Like, where did all the funding go?
I went in a circle.
I got confused.
Where does my guy tell me to go?
I went in a circle and I confused myself now.
I assume it's this way.
Probably make, no, I don't think it's going to make back 300
million.
That's a lot of money.
I don't think they're going to make anything back.
Oh, that went the wrong way.
I went the wrong way.
God, I fucking confused myself where I was supposed to go.
I actually went backwards.
Okay, then it should be this way then.
Yeah.
Wait, it's over there?
How do I get over there?
It is here.
Oh my god.
The Poison Swamp is doing more DPS than anything else in
this game.
It's like all just it's just all Poison Swamp because I'm
lost and confused.
Team Player, Poison Swamp.
shit and I'm gonna burn myself where's my blue smell the
pathway Musashi okay it's this way I figured it out wait is
it this way wait I lower it maybe I lower
this oh my god that was the entire that was the entire
solution this entire time Oh my god, it's dad's fault.
This is all his fault.
He made me so confused.
I should use some heals real quick.
Alright, that looks like a boss pit.
You're going down now.
You can't be here anymore.
That looks like a boss pit.
Alright.
Alright, he's gonna come back soon.
Don't worry.
He's gonna come back and yell at me very soon, I believe.
Oh, I was just thinking it would be fun.
Alright, time to steal the rift.
They are prepared to fight.
Let's do this.
Do you know if it's not a boss pit?
I still don't want to deal with it.
I don't want to hold on to the bad world.
Alright, cheer up.
Oh my god, it's always you.
Cheerio.
Oh, it's always you.
It's always you!
always okay all right get out of here always you can't be
doing this to me come on come on
oh man only i still had the blue if only oh my god you may
not survive oh my god please
Believe in me Believe in me, my wife Okay, there you go Nice
My wife just has to believe
She'll believe in me, right?
Okay
We're done here I'm gonna shrink that real quick.
Oh, I know there's more.
I knew it.
I had a feeling.
Welcome back.
What?
Okay, that's bullshit.
All right, there you go.
There you go.
Okay, I'll use extra stack.
You're hopeless!
That's right, you are!
Okay.
There you go.
Are you hearing?
Oh!
That's close, that's close, that's close, that's close.
Just try and stop.
Get out of here!
Got your head!
How's this?
Yeah!
Okay, I should be able to- No, you bitch!
Can you heal, actually?
Alright, nice.
No!
There you go.
Jesus!
Okay, wait, maybe I can grab this.
Nice.
Boom!
My turn, bitch!
Oh, that was close.
Can I get a stance break?
Can I do a quick heal?
Alright.
There you go.
You're so close.
Oh.
Nice.
One more headshot.
Oh, there's another.
You still have a...
You're still alive!
Oh, not this one.
Okay, that's fine.
I made it just...
Okay, nice.
The palace strength could start with him.
No!
Can you keep up?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
No, I can't.
I can't keep up.
Okay.
It's not looking grim.
It's not looking good!
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, one more.
Good.
I locked in there.
I locked in.
Oh!
I actually, I sat up.
Like, I sat up straight.
You know that meme when you lock in.
I actually sat up straight.
right there.
Wizard!
Welcome back from the concert.
Did you enjoy the concert?
Did you enjoy Oro Papa?
A fun vault.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You have fun.
I'm glad you had a good time.
Oh, don't worry.
I've already lowered it.
Apparently I was playing this game originally in 60 FPS.
I wonder if anyone recorded, I hope someone recorded a
reaction to Yuro Papa.
I really want to see the fan reaction to it, just because
I'm the most proud of that particular song.
Just because I was like, guys, you don't understand.
Rapping in Dutch is not as easy as you, the Dutch language
is very hard.
There's any...
Oh, that sounds...
Oh, shit.
It's wine time.
That's true.
That's so true.
I mean, he's just trying to be on the winning side, you
know?
I can go for it now.
He's just trying to be on the winning side.
Get them gutted.
Cleaned.
I mean, if a fucking giant demon was like, help me or I'll
eat you, I think...
How positively horrible.
I think I'm sorry, but I would pick not getting eaten.
Alright, nice safe boy.
So, hmm, so Doki will sell out her kind to be made into
monster wine.
I'll now confirm or deny this claim.
I'll never tell Guess we'll never know what she will and
won't she will or not do It sure is some mystery
Helpful to you at this Alright we got rice ball Do I have
enough for it actually I'm trying to remember that Which
Which one was it?
The...
It was this.
How much do I need?
Oh, I need one more!
I need one more.
Well, you rather be eaten by a demon?
Come on.
Get off your high horse.
I know you'll do the same thing.
Hey.
You want to be made into a human wine?
Just that easy?
Here, hold this.
the super chat they could think what the fuck that's it oh i
guess that's just it that's how he's just gonna die oh wait
he was not even human he's an or me that's shooting doji is
that easy to kill an orna soon enough i
thought only were like you know a step above human you that
samurai from before you saw nothing and nobody of course but
where's the woman woman that's what shoot and doji is after
bring me the prettiest girl in the village she said his lust
is insatiable bro disgraceful that's what he was up to to
eat right to eat right do you think i could play that role i
think don't know she's not real
I was just like, yeah, I was like, yes, what the fuck are
you talking about, bro?
You're not even real.
The prettiest girl in the village reporting for duty.
Bro, you're transparent.
That's good.
Everything all right.
Oh, I'm so scared.
Open it.
It's just her aura again.
You get revenge for everyone he's eaten.
Someone help me.
The monk has returned!
Yeah!
Come on, stop shaking!
Shut up.
And plus one RP, plus one RP.
Just guys, it sounds so real.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, it's a party party.
Holy shit, I think we might as well just fucking have to
host...
If we really want to get rid of demons that badly, just host
a jab party.
They'll kill each other eventually.
At this point.
I think that's the key.
Shizuka, it's been too long.
They'll eventually just kill themselves.
Me and the homies.
I knew you were behind this.
These guys are...
How does this even work?
He threw his lot in with Yoshitsune and guided the Gema to
the upper strata of hell.
Oh!
How is the other only so tiny and this one's so fucking big?
I guess that means the friend of that bastard fake monk!
If one values one's life, one must march with the strong.
He's a little creep.
Common sense in troubled times.
Is that what Yoshitsune and Tokyo told you?
You can't tell you're being used.
Idiot.
No, your place!
Oh, fuck.
I am Suden Doji.
Again, my boy, Tokyo's hand.
With the strength of every human and on the active.
Oh!
Pedal card right there.
What the hell are you bragging about?
Oh, he's an Oni and Genma now?
That's not your strength.
You just took it from others.
I guess because he like devoured like human souls, right?
It's like the worm lady.
Not that I'm any better.
So like, oh, because when he devours human souls, they like
turn more monstrous, right?
You pair well with my wife.
Okay, this is going to be bad because from what I'm told.
No!
From what I'm told.
He is a lot hard.
He's very hard.
Oh, he steals.
That's bullshit!
Can't have that.
Oh my god, he's using Drunken Master.
Oh my god, this is actual drunken master fight.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
He's so strong.
Okay, I actually have to walk in.
There we go.
I don't know if I should...
Okay, he doesn't have any more liquor in there, so I'm going
to go with the head.
Alright.
Riffy's cheating!
How do you fight against a drunk man?
What?
Oh, that stuns me?
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
Oh, shit.
Okay, there you go.
I have to dodge more, I think, for sure.
Jesus!
Oh my god.
He's so...
What?
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I need to dodge more versus blocking, deflecting.
There you go.
When he does that, I'll dodge.
Alright, I should be able to grab this.
What?
Alright, nice.
It was folly to challenge me.
Okay.
One hit.
I'm gonna grab...
I'm gonna aim for this one.
Just because he still has some...
Yeah, he has some liquor in there.
Nice.
Oh, I didn't grab that!
Delicious.
Okay, I should be able to hit this.
Nice!
Got your knees!
so so simple all right
nice attacking hell with me sitsune he's slaughtering the
orny and lining up their severed hands i'll never forget
that thrill get out of here silence for all your posturing
is great strategy oh i know he has a second phase that guy
begs for a sec he's he's calling it calling it for me too oh
and he can use fire oh okay oh when he does that roll all
right offer up your flesh to me Jesus I can't dodge that I
can't defend that it's so hard all right okay I got this one
oh it's over maverick thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you it's so hard to time for me I have a problem time
in that particular move I know it's not over it's not that
easy It's just I know it's the first price.
I know it's not that easy, too I'm ready for phase two
There's no way There's gotta be a part two.
There's no way it's just that easy.
Oh, I fucking do it Fucking do it Now comes the fun fight
Oh, we can't beat him!
Oh, I love a 2v1 situation!
No head?
Bow down to me, Shizuka.
Once I destroy the two-be-one!
Tokyo!
And claimed my rightful place at the top.
There is always a face, too.
I'll grant you again a body of your own.
Bow down to you.
A floating head.
True!
Get him!
Some shame.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Oh.
Where's my HP?
It must have been so hard not to scream.
How the fuck am I supposed to know?
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
A scripted.
Oh, where's my elf?
Shut your damn mouth, monster.
Oh, thank god it was scripted.
Like you has no right to laugh at us.
What's so funny?
Huh?
My how the weak do how.
It's true.
Truly hilarious.
You're right.
I am weak.
No, don't say that.
No, you're...
We're just good enough.
Shizuka isn't.
Takamura isn't.
Okuni isn't.
Masashi.
The strength I like.
He's acting.
The strength I need.
It's gonna all...
They have it.
By the power of friendship.
Oh!
Exulting!
Rescue!
Ori departed.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Turning me to a hurry.
Give me every ounce of power that you have.
In return.
Oh shit!
He's going super saiyan!
Let's go send that bum day.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I don't cut Yoshitsune down.
Ah, he blew.
Okay.
You mean to say when the waking gauge is full, I'm
continuing to the gauges and when only the damage all right
let's see who's really weak here us for you okay I'm trying
I'm using shock upon those words all right oh my god the
only place you'll be standing I'm trying to use as much bro
this is a lie and use only how pressing out allows you to
find Pavel skill bring end to your awakening time we're
gonna now.
Oh, that's all I do.
That's it.
Okay.
To be fair.
I, I really thought there would be more.
Oh my god, that's so bullshit.
Okay.
I, this is bullshit.
This is actually 2v1.
my god that's unfair i have to look at him for the grab i
got dead oh my god do i do i have to do it from the very
beginning okay thank god okay that's i'm fine with that
honestly i'm so fine with that
i'm i'm okay i'm not lost forever bring it to baron him
before it things i'm okay I'm honestly okay with that
scenario Okay, I feel like the fact that I have to like keep
both of them in view It's so hard Oh my god No I need to
know, okay, and with this move In this move, he does that
Okay now i know when he does the play move
all right all right no i have okay here we go oh get that
head no head oh head
Okay.
Get out of my face!
I got it!
I got the stagger too!
Alright.
Okay, I need to remember.
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
I didn't know what that was!
Okay, well now I do.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm tri- Okay, I got it.
I got it.
All right, I'm gonna grab this for now.
All right, I'll heal here.
Now is the time.
Unleash your true might as an only mission.
Unibu shaitan!
Yeah.
It's okay.
I'll grab this.
It's over.
He can use that move, but I have ultimate move.
Do I miss?
I miss!
Classic Toki!
Okay.
A very critical missile.
Oh, toky.
Classic toky.
All right.
This is power.
This is strength.
All right, we got it.
He got this.
Oh, it's out.
It's done!
Surely it's not!
This is it.
I can't miss this!
You can't miss this!
Oh!
Finish him!
There we go.
Can't miss this though.
Alright, second try?
Come on.
Second try.
Dude, there's no way there's this game.
He literally fucking Tony Stark himself.
I feel like I took a step along my path today.
All right, now you come back if you want.
I finished the boss tape.
Just one.
How was that before?
He's an easier Anoni state.
Oh, really?
Okay, I'll try that next step.
Let's stray from the path and become lost like Yoshitsune or
Gambu.
Thanks.
He's blushing.
Oh,
I locked.
I told you I locked it.
I got the power of Oni inside me.
I started going super saiyan.
No.
Wait a minute.
To me, the way of the sword is simple.
It's a game of strength.
If you win, you're the strongest.
Exactly.
I'm so trying.
And humble.
If it takes the power of the Oni.
I'm literally the strongest in the world.
Ah, she's so humble.
And win against the Genma.
That's still winning.
The second I realized that didn't bother me anymore.
The departed Oni entrusted you with their strength.
That's profound.
Musashi, detours are a part of any journey.
And the way of the sword is not a path that must be walked
alone.
that would be true with the only gauntlet or without all
that matters is that you forge your head yeah lady marasaki
i have a slight genma problem at yasaka shrine just a little
can't be that bad right
Just a little problem.
Just come whenever it's convenient.
See, she didn't buy Doki prior.
That's not her.
She just said sort of a little problem.
Can't exactly turn her down.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki.
Just got off ER on day one on vacation.
Thanks for being watching.
Of course.
How are we feeling better?
How are we doing okay, Papa?
Give me the super chat.
Thank you.
journey by foot and by foot instead you want me to walk
there are you crazy
and who do you think you are telling me to walk all right
there is several like a peasant exactly me from deep makes
your health and only regenerate over time Only power.
I don't know.
I feel like...
My latest masterpiece.
I always... I think HP is better.
Honestly.
I mean...
An only power over...
Generate over time.
I don't know.
I don't think regeneration means much to me as the others.
Mani, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki, it's my birthday today.
Happy birthday for my wish.
Of course you can!
Oh, wait.
Get my reality and force.
You must know that you purified a key sanctuary.
I think that we driven them a corner but i can't shake the
feeling that yoshu yosichu and dokyo are up to something our
lives just beyond one lies just beyond the only gate
awaiting his chance well the other will you know where
she'll show up next i just wish we could strike first yes of
course manix of course happy birthday to you happy birthday
to you happy birthday dear manix happy birthday to you yeah
happy birthday and thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you Oh, we have a great birthday.
All right, I have a lot saved up for this, too.
So, when you extend the duration and increase the power,
yummy.
All right, and we have third charm, too.
Thank God.
We actually need to unlock that.
Is there anything else to unlock?
I guess not.
So, let's grab a third charm.
um what are the other charms blazing state duration increase
i feel like increase regular power honestly that's all those
pairs that i saved up for for this one moment um all right
where is there we go nice all right and then we have some
drills we gotta do Ring a ding ding Ring a ding ding
Alright, let's grab some extra items From these drills Uh,
countering stance What's this one?
Let's get started I remember what this one is Oh, it's this
Okay Uh, alright, we know what this is I need you to do your
countering stance How am I supposed to...
Come on, start cathering.
There we go.
Boom!
And I do it?
Oh, to defeat all the Gemma now.
Alright, there you go.
Yeah, over here.
Go over out.
I figured you- Oh shit, never mind!
Never mind!
Ah, I'm sorry!
I didn't mean that!
Joki, you figured what out?
I figured him out, guys.
I figured it out.
I did it.
I...
Guys, I told you I figured it out.
Alright, fire, bird fluke.
Let's get started.
Alright, there you go.
I don't think I really need to learn how to do this.
I don't think it's just bird time.
Bird, bird, bird!
Bird, bird!
Bird!
There you go.
Nice.
I birded.
Yay!
All right.
What else?
Flashing wood.
Which one's this?
Oh, it's this.
All right.
Boom!
Oh, shit.
That was instant.
That's crazy.
Yep.
How many times I can recharge?
Oh, I can charge it all the way to the end.
Alright, that's strong for the...
I assume it's strong for the little guys, but it doesn't
really matter for the big...
Big bosses, I always use the Earth Shatter.
Just because I'd rather just break the thing.
Okay, let's try...
Apparently it's easier to ease him.
Okay.
Don't worry, I'll figure it out.
it out don't worry all right don't worry oh my god all right
it's are we figuring it out i said we figured we definitely
figured it out
take that's not all the way down i guess so it's taking yeah
but like if i if i have the the the blue stuff for it if
only she did ease it one day we'll see it one day all right
actually yeah i want to go grab this first wait there's
another dog here why is there a dog here what is this dog
how did this dog get here Why did...
Guys, what?
Guys, guys, you guys all have hands too.
You all have eyes.
Why am I the one getting him?
He's literally in our neighborhood.
What's...
Yeah, what the fuck's the dog doing?
He was literally in our neighborhood.
Alright, this way.
They don't care.
Will anyone please?
Think of the dogs!
Alright.
We'll grab the mission.
Um, no.
This is definitely not like the previous Onimusha games, I
will say.
As someone that has played the first two Onimusha games, um,
it is very different from...
From the classic.
Uh...
But it's still fun.
It's more souls-like now.
I will...
say is the more souls like onimusha game i hello little kids
where are your parents mr samurai i was looking for you that
is not a child that's a 80 year old man you gave me your
onigiri under the bridge oh when i was getting ready to
fight the yoshioka school those yoshioka people were praying
here to the hanging monkeys all right that's a 40 year old
30 40 year old child wishes or something don't know but they
made scary faces and said grump me the power to kill musashi
grump me the power to kill musashi i am four years old
around me is bound to get you in trouble so run along yeah
okay I've noticed.
What's left of the Yoshioka school awaits you at Rendino?
I wonder.
What kind of story will fanning their vengeful flames bring?
Isn't your shrine being overrun by Genma right now?
Like...
Oh, there's a riff ahead of me.
What will you do?
Wait, why am I here?
Not sure.
Oh, did he feed me?
That's nice.
Oh, they like transported me here.
I didn't say, why am I here?
We've been waiting for you, Miyamoto Musashi.
Hello?
I'll keep this short.
You have no hope against me.
My god went from one boss fight to the next vanish Do you
remember this is the place where you cut down our master?
Oh my god.
It's from the tutorial Since that day we thought about oh
shit, but revenge about how we could kill you Bro, okay, but
I cut I killed him when I was a regular person like I don't
think this is gonna oh is did he did they become nui or
gedma oh he went to they went to the dark side for only our
humanity and a small tribute we have gained strength far
greater than yours
they got him oh the parasite yeah oh not gonna lie this guy
looks like he He has balls for a mouth.
Stupid bastards.
Oh shit, it's a 1v3.
Oh my god, they're going to gang up on me.
Completely fallen to the game though.
Oh no.
Doesn't make a difference.
I'm cutting them down either way.
Alright, nice.
Broke the stats at least.
Here we go.
Alright, maybe you guys are not not gonna lie.
I think you might think it might not have been as strong as
you think you are.
You might...
Maybe you got the power when I just got the godlet, buddy.
This is a little...
This is a little sad, bro.
Alright, your turn.
I swear to God, if he has a face to you, though, I swear to
him.
If they do, I'm keeping my...
I'm keeping my coolers for now.
Just in case.
Alright.
There, I'll let you have one hit.
There.
Just for a little treat, I'll let you have one hit before
you die.
They unleashed their potential, but they didn't have much
potential.
Uh, what?
What?
Excuse me.
Um, I sliced you in half.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Oh, they're that type of GENMA.
Alright, thank god.
I...
Alright, well, it's time.
Alright.
Good thing I have.
Well done.
Alright, good thing I have.
What the fuck?
Alright.
Alright, get out of here.
I'm gonna heal just in case you come back for the third
time.
Like...
All right, get out of here.
They didn't even get to use their glowing sword once.
All right.
Round three?
So please stay down.
This is embarrassing for you and me now.
All right, goodbye.
Are we good to go?
Some people will do anything for a bit of power.
Anything?
That was it?
Okay, that has to be the...
For how late game that was, that was the easiest like,
Murasaki missions.
Like, I would...
One desire, and they will grant another in exchange.
That, yeah.
That one was a little bit of a letdown.
In their desire to kill Misashi and exact their
anti-climatic, yeah.
Kind of sad.
into giving up their humanity.
This tale ended as I predicted.
The sad end of foolish warriors who were...
It was pretty sad.
Their own flesh of the fire to stoke the flames of their
vengeance.
How heart-wrenching.
It was very, very sad.
I think it might have been the easiest Murasaki mission I've
got.
Quail, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Hey, Doki, we're going to go into hiding because there's no
way to hide in the village because the demons took over.
Everyone else has given up on a samurai, but I still believe
he'll show up soon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'll be there soon.
You guys got Doki priority, right?
You guys upgraded, didn't you?
You upgraded Doki priority, right?
Right?
Yeah, that felt like a filler arc.
It did.
thank you wait what there are rifts besieging yasaka shrine
from the perimeter wait if we go out this way i'm just
opening the door for the genma better to find a way around
the outside what's the wait you guys saw that right there
was a blue aura oh that's weird maybe it's just outside i
want to do all right there's another mirasaki mission here
all right oh yeah sorry the yeah the the rate has increased
though for dokey priority because I did get some upgrades so
so you might have to pay 20% extra now thanks to you our
troop is back up and running all that's left is to wait for
our cooney to come back that said there's something I'd like
to talk to you about one of our regulars seems to have had a
run in with what
nightly or so he says night parade put simply it's a large
procession of spirits They say you'll be killed.
I'll encounter the nightlight.
That is, unless you have a certain charm on you.
Like what?
If he lived to tell the tale.
Yes.
Thankfully he had a charm on him.
The only problem is he dropped it when he was running away.
He's so scared that he might run into them again.
He won't leave.
not your bravest customer i hope i'll see if i can find it
for him how very kind of you thank you
the night parade what an intriguing tale i owe at the night
parade made the whole thing up the charm must be around here
somewhere Oh no.
Now it's hard.
She was energetic.
I love like the night look parade.
I believe she handles the troops advertising.
Her energy certainly seems like it would draw a crowd.
All right.
I want...
It's right here.
The night parade.
All right.
I like night parade lore in Japanese lore.
I think it's very interesting.
I love like the designs and stuff from night parades.
the demon-only designs, they do.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, night parade of the demons.
Oh, all right.
It's over here.
I assume it'd be easier.
I'll grab all of these missions, too, first.
This place is covered in malice.
It's not just rifts, but those weird malice plants, too.
All right.
Oh, they upgraded defenses now.
Well, it's nothing I can't handle.
Good for them.
They finally added more than just one man.
Can't believe this is happening.
Homie, uh, would you, mister?
I accidentally overfed my...
It just kept growing now they're about yours.
I don't think they're fish anymore, woman.
You're absolutely certain.
Yeah, I was gonna say, are you sure they're fish, if not
monsters?
Well, I saw some shadows lurking beneath the water.
You know how fish are.
But he really was a monster that I have eaten.
But yeah, I was gonna say, are you sure?
What happened?
I know it is.
Why didn't I eat...
No!
Why did I eat them first?
Would you go and take a look for me?
Oh, it's gonna be the...
Oh, thank God.
My favorite mission.
Don't worry, I'll do it for you guys.
The big diddy water monsters.
Hello.
Mr. You look pretty tough.
I'll bet a little crush or two wouldn't buy you in the
slightest, would it?
Think you could take one wand for me?
A ghost came to me this at Yasser Stran.
Said it was a treasure map.
It was like, oh my god, another treasure map.
All right, guys, we gotta do this.
Talk about scary.
I know that ghost, you could say we're friends.
Anyone put curse on you?
Don't worry.
All right, you know what?
It is sort of time, though.
I can feed him now.
Oh my god, what the fuck was that bark?
I gave him the rest of his food.
It is time now.
I looked at it.
I looked at the time.
And I was like, you know what?
it is time well thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you our last mission to get i would like to pay for the
souls of those innocent lives lost at mount oa but seems
they're not content to rest instead they roam okay
ceaselessly tormented by now say instead some of them even
try to attack me it's almost as if they're offended by my
prayers but they're trying to tell me it's all in vain
perhaps they spurn the spitty of a coward who could only run
away and not stand and fight.
Those really are the souls of the dead.
I doubt they attack someone who's praying for them.
I don't think there's souls at all.
I think there are more unwelcome visitors from the
underworld.
Wait here while I take care of those little shits.
Alright.
I can't wait to fight my ex again.
Why can't I quit you?
Alright, we're gonna grab.
Okay, where are all of these missions?
Okay, there's Damn, there's one...
Oh my god, fucking course your treasure is over there.
Oh, fucking course.
Alright, do the Murasaki mission first, since it's the
closest.
Alright.
Take me there, my little Navi.
Take me there.
Take me home.
Go to the place.
Where I belong.
We guys saw that, right?
Why does it do that?
They, like, glowed blue, but, like, nothing showed up.
I'm a little confused.
I don't know why it glowed.
You see these?
No?
See?
Okay.
Oh, that was a little... Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
He's back here!
Oh!
I wanted to watch the night parade!
No!
My five seconds of the night parade.
No night parade for me, I guess.
Oh my, I assume that.
I saw one second of that.
It took me.
It's the night parade castle.
Oh, wait.
Another game I patrol in the area.
Can't get to see another one.
Okay, good.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
I can...
All right, take two.
Take two.
It'll probably go better than searching for that charm is.
All right, at least I get another chance.
All right.
Where is it?
I assume it's, like, inside.
Hello?
Any night paraders?
Any night paraders inside?
Okay, it's not from this direction.
Uh, I assume it's...
How do I get there?
Is this destination reached?
I don't know.
How do you get inside there?
Is there the other way?
I guess it's like the other way.
Oh my god, this one's a little bit of a hidey hole.
It's actually hiding from me.
Oh.
Oh, I hear it.
Oh, there they are.
Look at them.
Oh, that's cool.
That's pretty cool.
I
like that.
Alright, let's kill them.
They should prove no much.
Alright, I was going to say there's no way you can dodge
that.
Alright.
Oh my god, I just want to make sure his eyes are gone.
Alright, it's time!
Fire!
Fire, fire, fire.
Just in case.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Alright, come on, bro!
Oh my god.
I fucking hate you.
I actually hate you so much.
Oh, thank god.
Got him.
Alright, you.
Oh, now you're two?
Oh, not you two.
all right all right nice okay he didn't fight back thank god
we're done here thank god he didn't fight back oh that's my
favorite and among them very dangerous present it's my
favorite when they just don't fight back she got the large
procession part right now that we saw what the night parade
is now i can just interrupt it the entire time the third one
is a bit annoying all right let's go let's see how we're
let's see how this gonna go assume it's like here all right
i do still have my owny so i'll use my owny for it oh is
that lore all right can't wait for my lore game i get my
lord a nice find oh wait there's loot here i love you just
fuel for the coordinates i mean sure i'll take this
there you go all right that seemed easy nice it was i'm
gonna get rusty oh nice okay we need that That's actually
crafting materials.
The guy got a little too excited.
Oh, wait, I just realized I haven't eaten yet.
Whoops.
Okay.
I should order.
Oh, what the fuck?
Where did you come from?
There's two.
Oh, shit.
How do you have so...
Oh, my God.
You fucker.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
It's because there was two of you.
Oh my god, I hate you.
I hate you so much.
I...
You'll get snow bench.
There you go.
Get out of here.
God, I hate these guys.
These guys are the worst!
And the other common enemies, these guys are the worst ones.
For sure.
Where the fuck is that parade?
But after I fight this, I'll reward myself.
Oh!
Okay Oh Okay Okay
Oh shit How did they find out?
Fire, fire, fire Fire All right, I got used to only on this
guy Now it's Okay
No, I'm just gonna use it.
Spy.
No longer fine, I didn't use my special move!
I couldn't use my special move.
I'm just going to be sad.
No, where am I?
Okay, this is actually...
Alright, this is actually very interesting.
All right.
You gotta heal right now.
Here it comes.
Oh, this is so bad for me.
I need to get rid of as many attacks, many of them as
possible.
Okay.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Give up, give up!
All right.
Now you.
now you oh please don't tell me you separate all right might
be able to get rid of him too you bastard all right you
fucking you
You!
You're so lucky!
Your big brother is here!
You're so...
It's so lucky your big brother came in.
Oh my god!
Okay.
You're so...
Oh my.
Please.
Okay.
Oh!
Ah!
Shit!
Don't give them a knife!
No!
Okay.
Oh my god.
All right.
Okay.
What are you cool about?
Oh
my god.
all right drill
got one all right nice x x i've got you x you freak go don't
give them it oh my god there is not a lot of damage i did
there not me no like
Okay.
Mino like that.
If.
Oh, my gosh.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh!
I'm a better buddy masher!
I'm a better buddy masher than you!
I know I am!
all right oh that's it i knew i knew i had to fight i why
can't i quit you my fucking ex she always comes back what do
i have there something i picked up you think this is the
charm we're looking for I think it may well be.
I sense no remaining game or presence either.
We should go and return it.
Alright.
We got this.
That third one was annoying.
He was right.
He was so right.
My crazy axe girlfriend.
Regular can go home in peace.
I'll hand it back to him right away.
Masashi.
Thank you for this.
Bye.
oh she's so quirky i hope she continues to have that winzy
in her i wouldn't bet on that charm against an army of
spirits so quirky
in my food one little charm may prove ineffective against
the night parade
I don't know where it's fake but it has no power at all I
did I did all that and it was a bootleg and yet to that
owner it grants the ability to disperse their paralyzing
fear can't believe it all that just for a bootleg mysterious
ways Don't you think?
Oh, I did all that.
Just for it to be fake.
Until next time.
Yeah.
Not yet.
Me not happy about that.
Now I'm gonna get...
I'm gonna get some...
I'm gonna get...
Rice maybe?
Ooh, wait, maybe I'll get some...
Mmm...
Let's see.
What do they have?
They have rice balls.
I'm gonna guild on.
I'm gonna guild on in a while.
I'll get a guild on with a pan with a souffle pancake.
It's my first meal of the day.
Oh, I'll get a mango soda.
Mango soda.
Ooh.
Alright, guys.
Do I get a or a smoothie?
Actually, I want to get a smoothie.
Wait, this sounds good.
A usual schmooly.
Okay.
Alright, remove the items.
Why does it say it doesn't have it?
Okay, now it does.
Alright.
What kind of?
I want to get pancake too.
I want to get fluffy pancake.
It's a usual schmooly.
Never had that before.
Sounds nice.
I'll get a a There's fluffy pancakes, because I like fluffy
pancakes.
Got everything I want.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, what are our missions do I have to do?
Okay, we gotta get the fishing area.
So, let's go over there real quick.
I haven't had fluffy pancakes in so long.
Okay, where is this Lord?
It's somewhere close to me.
He's, like, calling for me.
You can't just call for me and be like, JK.
Ma'am, this is an emergency hotline.
You know that's illegal, right, ma'am?
Alright, it has to be.
Oh, my God.
I think it's literally outside.
I actually think it's outside, though.
um can i afford this okay i can finally run faster now um do
i actually want all the way down here uh increase the speed
which items can be used let's grab all that since i have the
money might as well have a lot of souls inside me
anything else that i want to use here there's one final i
don't think any of the items matter that much to me because
there is one final item um just for fun i'll grab this just
for fun
what about the fine okay i don't have enough i was gonna say
i was like fine i'll do it I realize I don't even have
enough.
Ooh, wait, this matches my sword.
I'm gonna grab that.
Um, we'll go to, we'll kill the big titty water monsters
now.
Oh, this way.
Comes with some power-ups, too, so that's always good.
Alright, let's go.
kill the big titty water monster oh loot though big titty
water monsters let's go where are they i'm getting ready
dual wield hello ah i knew it
honestly yeah what else could it be oh okay well that's on
here she fucking rolled into the pie that's on here all
right it's just that fulfills the request that's these oh my
that was it cooked fish yay free food they got some free
food though
let's see there's any i did get a upgrade where it was
supposed to be more items dropped but i guess that was a lie
all right um let's grab the goddamn owning treasure i hate
the treasure hunts though the treasure hunts are so annoying
i might need you guys to help me because i'm gonna be so
lost Hey guys, I'm just going to kill you.
For extra money.
I need the money.
Get out of here!
No challenge.
Alright, nice.
Alright, just rob them a little bit.
And then...
Oh, I'm not locked.
You know, this would have helped a lot.
I got this upgrade in the beginning.
But I think about it.
Maybe I nerfed myself a little.
too hard uh jingle jangle trick thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you wow i'm surprisingly very fast right now
it's a little awkward
is this we could have saved a lot of time all right where is
this at one of the buildings oh my god can i get my king
back oh that's annoying i made it easy Yeah, I did.
Honestly.
Is there any more?
Alright, we gotta figure out where this is.
There's more over there?
Yeah, I put it all on bow.
Finish the bow!
Bow is so strong!
I just want a pew pew.
That too much.
Look at that.
Come on.
Is that too much to ask for?
Oh, so strong.
All right.
Yeah, really?
This is embarrassing for you and me.
I have to fight you.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
You thought you got me there?
All right.
Nice.
Alright, where the fuck is this place?
Hey, check out this thing I found.
Yo, bro, look, check this out, bro.
Alright, where...
It should be, like, here, right?
What the fuck?
Okay, he's got me this step.
He's got me, he's got me.
Alright, I admit, he's got me.
All right, you got me, bro.
You got me real good, bro.
You did
Oh, God.
What the fuck, bitch?
Okay.
Bye.
Think fast!
It should be up here, right?
Alright, where are the houses?
What the fuck?
Alright.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Oh, bitch.
I know I started with X this time.
How did I miss?
Alright, get out of here.
Yeah, you are.
Your life is meaningless.
You have no purpose!
It should be somewhere here.
Whoops.
All right, there we go.
Oh, that's a lot of riffs.
I hope somebody closes them.
Quite a find.
That doesn't mean this to good use.
I do hope someone closed those riffs.
All right, let's see.
Let us go.
I know there's one more.
I just don't know which map it is on.
We're gonna have to find the mirror.
Oh, man.
This neighborhood sure went to shit.
I do hope someone fixes that.
Like, I can't be the only Uber samurai.
You know?
Can't just only be me.
All right, let's see.
I don't really know where the other missions are, so I'm
just going to scroll through until I see stuff.
Just gotta be sure.
And look at all these dogs.
I don't know if I did all of them.
That's the thing.
Did I do all of them?
I think I did.
Oh, nope.
There's one here.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh
These only I'm gonna say it but those only stones and hemp
and cloth they're not that worth it I will say that I'm I
think this will be the one minute.
I'm gonna I'm goodbye They are surprisingly not that worth
it I legitimately hate those these quests the most it's just
really frustrating and the fact that it's not in one area
too I have to travel around what a relief they really were
monsters after all well okay your fish is I don't know man I
don't know man about that it might come back you know if you
want to eat those fish of yours now's the time that very
thought I have you know that I said that in the heat of the
moment Mr. Samurai and I don't care to be reminded of it hmm
My pantry is perfectly well supplied.
Well, for now at least.
Besides, you're starting to fad up nicely.
You can use it to catch bigger fish.
Alright, see I got only stone from her.
I legitimately don't think I need the other ones.
Alright, let's see.
Let's buy...
How much money do I have?
Let's go...
Let's go to the bowman and buy some stuff.
There's always bigger fish.
Exactly.
All right, let's get iron and temper iron.
All right, I think I have enough.
I don't know.
I've been farming a lot.
So let's see.
I anticipated your visit, Musashi.
Oh, really?
I don't believe you.
Goodbye.
Buy one.
So I don't really have that much money.
Correct.
you farewell my friends i'm just spending i don't know how
much i need for the next one so i'm just gonna buy one for
now and then see all right go all in on damage okay before
okay i don't have enough all right i have enough i think i
anticipated your visit musashi it's nice that he also gives
me upgrades oh never mind i don't farewell my mom broke i'm
broke Alright.
Not enough.
Oh, that's fine.
Let's just do the mission now.
Um, okay.
Let's go do it.
Okay, Poison Swab Electric.
Ooh, lookaloo.
Poison Swab 3.
How?
All right, get out of here.
Oh, my God.
Musashi, please!
How do I get up there?
All right.
There we go.
Just out of here.
You feed poison swamps, dude.
It's your favorite!
It's your favorite fight in the entire game!
But everybody always loves the poison swamps!
In fact, I wish they added more.
I wish every other level was a poison swarm.
The more I think about it.
Honestly felt like...
Lost potential right there.
Alright.
Fuck it.
It's dangerous up there.
I'm like, nope.
Yeah, I hear you.
Nope.
I just love poison swap so much, guys.
You don't understand.
Ah, it's bad.
I could have abused that.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, don't make me.
Oh, that's it.
That's it.
Bird, bird.
Oh, that's it.
You'll make me mad.
make me bird but I will bird you know what fuck it that's
right that's right I will use my only powers oh my god you
better spawn quick quick spawn up bro I how long do I have
to chop you till you spawn there's no escape All right.
There we go.
I did waste it a little bit, though.
All right.
Oh, I can suck it from here.
Yeah, I wasted the only form.
Unlucky.
Because I saw the only thing there next to me.
We're fighting every day.
better be getting stronger is there another i don't know if
i took that one there's an only thing over here but i don't
know if i took it did i yeah i took it okay we gotta go this
way
unlucky oh oh now it gives me two eye okay should have
bought the temper iron i guess
Smash!
Where?
Oh, there.
Okay, first off, you gotta be able to aim.
You ain't piercing anybody's hearts.
Alright.
Yay!
Let's go this way.
There was a loot box here and yep all right up we go
okay yummy yummy loot yeah
oh i hear some on honest groaning behind me
oh there's loot up whoa oh it's just you be on your guard oh
my god what No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I refuse.
Okay, get over here.
I will chop your eye.
I don't care.
No, fucking hell.
Fucking course.
A fucking course you multiply.
You always multiply.
Okay.
Oh, I hate you.
I hate your entire being.
I hate you.
I hate your guys.
Whoa.
All right, there we go.
Whoa, dokey.
A troop.
I'm trying to figure out how to get.
Are you kidding me?
That's it.
I'm killing you.
I'm...
Oh my god, I can't even...
I get it!
Oh my god, he eats.
Oh my god, he eats you.
I also hate you.
I'm trying to figure out how to get to that tree!
Oh, there it is.
All right, there we go.
All right, nice.
Okay, now I'm a little... I can breathe a little bit more.
There's God.
I gotta get over there.
Okay, there's that little... Okay, I'm gonna steal a little
bit.
What?
Oh my god, is it all the way up there?
Did I miss something?
Oh, it is.
Oh, okay, I fucking course their skills now.
What?
Am I supposed to travel here?
Oh, there's another one.
Alright, my yellow paint.
be on your guard hello my fellow yellow paint i'm just gonna
throw this at all of you because i cannot be bothered right
now and then we're gonna go up the ladder on your guard i
swear to god bro i'm i'm gonna chop you down all right oh
you're so lucky
I hope you fucking fall down.
So, all right, there we go.
Get out of here.
I just need to chop that up before it.
Oh, there he is.
is
I'll start off with that Oh my god, are you serious?
It's not fair Okay, bro, come on You're so weak
You're Bro, it's sad that...
That's it.
I'm taking you out of that form.
It's so sad that you need...
You need help.
Come on, bro.
That's sad.
That you...
That you even need to...
What?
Bro, you bitch.
okay at least thank God all right what okay
I know I use why this time oh you got there you go there you
go there you go there I got it before I could put up.
Oh, knee!
Oh, where is he?
Oh,
fuck.
Oh, knee.
Oh, knee hurt.
Only form needs help.
Oh, he form needs help.
Can you keep up?
okay all right what oh god
oh my oh I'm so close you just oh I fucked it up I'm so sad
I will shoot them off the bridge.
I don't care.
I need to shoot them off the bridge.
Guys.
I'm so sad.
I'm not even...
Bye.
Okay, I have to get rid of the poison first.
Where is he?
No, I fixed the wrong one!
Don't grab the tree, baby!
I fixed the wrong one!
Everything can go wrong is going wrong!
Okay, here you go.
Here you go.
Oh,
fuck.
There.
I got that one out of the way.
How's this?
All right.
Here you go.
Oh, he's out, he's out, he's out, he's out, he's outing,
he's outing, he's outing.
No, I timed incorrectly.
Oh.
All right, there you go.
Oh, my God.
I keep timing incorrectly.
I don't know why.
All right.
Can you keep up?
I swear to God, yes I can!
Really?
I'm really good.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I don't know why.
He's like, he's in my head.
He's fucking playing.
He's mind-controlling me right now.
Oh, he's actually mind-controlling me.
well done it's in my head oh my god oh my god they're in my
head they're in my head I don't know what's going on
hands with you I'm getting them I'm getting behind
controlled I am I'm actually getting behind controlled right
now I did
I don't know what's going on.
Yes
Okay, okay, okay I'll fuck you course these start Guys,
I don't know what's going on
I don't know what's going on with me.
I don't know Okay, maybe I can go back up.
Maybe I can go back up now Oh little
okay it's gonna be different it's gonna be different this
time oh it's it'll be different starting now starting now
starting now starting now oh my god mind control
up.
I can't believe I can't get it off.
You made that easy.
Okay.
One strike.
All right.
Oh, you're going to use, you really need to use these guys
for cover.
Really.
All right.
You can't win.
I'll break your skull next.
Oh my god, you!
I got it!
Because I got it!
This is perfection!
Okay, I didn't get that one, though.
It's fine.
I got an Easton, though.
I got one.
Okay.
All right.
All right, there you go.
There you go.
But I got there you go.
all right there you go all right it's fine what
oh my god that cheater that
cheater all right oh my god i'm fucking oh he's literally
one he's literally What?
Alright, we did it.
We did it.
I had to greed that.
I had to greed.
I don't know.
I don't know what happened to me there.
He was in my head.
He actually fucking mind-controlled me.
Is that all for the riffs?
No.
Yes.
Nicely done.
Was in my head.
Lady Morosaki is unharmed.
I dealt with again, ma'am.
nothing to be scared of out here now I was not scared my
concentration was simply interrupted oh that was that easy
guys it sounded like the meme the foie it sounded like the
fucking tick-tock foie
Oh, we're there.
Oh, and Burai.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, pause.
You know, they're kind of growing on me.
Let's make a stop at Kenanji Temple.
Those two will make a good warm-up for Gunnu and Yoshitsu.
Okay.
Or another one.
Now I should be able to find oh, there it is.
There's the Lord I've been waiting for you oh it wasn't Lord
it was just beans or oh it not beans Huzuki nice we're level
four we got this as well we can enhance it again oh I need
like five Malachi Jesus Christ I'm not made up money I'm
poor Any extra stuff?
Oh, we can grab...
I'll grab that later, actually.
Alright, back to the house.
We go from one boss to the next.
Oh my god.
Back to back bosses?
Wait, I went the wrong way.
What?
Yeah, I know.
I just looked at that map.
Is there?
Wait, I'll grab that.
just for extra money.
I should need the money too.
Actually, I could grab the Oni.
I could farm these for Oni right now.
Might be a good idea.
Yeah, I'm just gonna kill them for some extra Oni.
Let's do this.
Oni juice.
Yeah, let's level that up.
I'm hungry, I gotta need some Oni juice.
Oh my god, just wagging it.
Whoops, I don't think you know.
I don't think you saw me.
Alright, nice.
Alright, last guy.
Okay, we need a power up really badly.
I don't know why I wanted to chop the beans.
I don't...
I started chopping them.
No, I want, like, not money.
I need, like, I want to power up my Oni stuff for the boss,
but so I can just go straight in and throw a bunch of combos
out.
You know?
Break his helmet.
Alright.
Okay.
We're almost close.
Whoa!
Wow!
I hate you so much.
You're actually- you're so annoying.
You're so annoying!
Nobody loves you!
Get out of here.
Give me your purple juice.
Oh, it's just money.
Yeah, but then I want to keep the blues, though.
That's the thing.
We gotta keep the blues.
the purple.
I don't want to waste my blue power for purple.
I think that's enough, though, right?
I think I farmed enough.
It should be fine.
I hope.
Unless there's more.
There might be more demons over there.
Oh, there it is.
It's like I heard I heard them loitering around.
Whoops.
Is that awkward?
Like how they have, like, different masks.
Oh, my God.
That's it.
There we go.
Yo!
That's it.
Again?
Bro, stop.
That's not going to work.
You're not going to expect it a second time.
Is that it?
Too bad shit.
I'm so bad at East.
You don't know.
I'm trying.
But every time I try to do it, they got me.
I don't know.
That's enough.
I'm gonna...
Actually, yeah, let's go in.
I think that should be enough.
What's with this Gale?
Oh my god.
Oh my...
I could have farmed it here.
I could...
What do you mean?
I could have farmed it here.
Is that a tornado?
It's coming this way.
What do you mean?
I'm gonna farm this.
How am I supposed to fight when dodging tornadoes?
All right.
All right, let's fight.
I'm just thinking what do you mean I could have I could have
five all of this right here inside oh my god this could have
been five there you go yeah fucking idiot all right get in
here
All right, here we go.
Oh.
That's it.
I'm using it.
I don't care.
It might have been a way, side to side.
Stay set.
I don't care anymore.
So eventually die.
All right, that's fine.
All right, fuck it.
Fire!
If it means less monsters to deal with, that's fine with me.
Well done.
Time to spam the X.
Ah, you too.
Ah, thanks.
There you go.
Get the Archer right now.
Archer down!
Shield Mad down!
Yeah, I should have enough, almost enough of Blues.
Yep, get that just in case.
That should be the last of it.
I swear to God, if this is going to be a 2v1, I swear to
God.
Yeah, I think God lightning doesn't strike twice.
Oh, I got Malakite.
I actually need that, too.
Alright, come back.
Come down.
Show yourselves.
If you want to fight, stop hiding.
Who's hiding?
That little temple just can't contain our power.
Oh.
Let's get born and warm.
Oh, wait, it's not.
Oh, they have a whole stadium for me.
It's pretty neat.
Oh, for little old meme shucks.
Oh, shucks.
Oh, for little old meme.
All right,
here we go.
I'm here, you two.
Don't keep me waiting.
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
Oh god again.
We've come up with the ultimate team at Power Place to bust
your skull.
Oh no.
2v1.
Oh, they just all 2v1?
Oh, no!
Where's my two?
Oh, nice.
Oh, they're not coordinated.
They're not coordinated.
Wait, there's a chance.
Oh no!
And our souls can soar.
Here.
He said...
That's what I'm doing it!
They're more predictable!
No, they're so predictable!
Oh, that was not predictable for me, I'm sorry.
Let's end this!
Okay, I don't know where I'm slashing this, so...
Alright.
Alright, nice.
I got one of them.
needed all right it's good for me that's good for me okay
that's fine there you go did you train for this yeah did you
looks like you did it only there you go
Oh, what do you mean?
There's a face down!
No!
I'm fighting!
Okay.
All right, we got the slash.
All right, there we go.
It's fine, it's fine.
Everything is fine.
There we go.
All right, it's fine.
Got it!
What?
I barely hate you!
That was bullshit!
That's party!
That's faulty!
These two are out of control.
No!
Get up!
Okay.
Damage!
Good.
No!
to the death you love the sound of that i don't know what to
do i don't know what to do okay
come on oh thank god okay
nice this ends now it's end now get him
All right, here we go.
Oh, he's so weak right now.
If you think you could stop us, take it again.
Okay.
We have to get rid of him.
Here we go.
Last brother.
Turn the boat.
One down.
Bring it on.
Oh, please.
Give me my one.
Only power.
It's over.
One is said that you're gone.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, fire.
All right.
Only power.
Holy shit All right George it's all right.
Oh, I keep forgetting.
I don't remember the timing for that Okay, it's fine It's
fine you've got
Headshot Oh, I wish I could do more damage for that though
That should be more damage, but it's not!
Let's make this flushing!
Okay, there you go.
How did you reach such a fast attack?
Apparently I...
I fucked up that!
Whoops!
Here's the breakdown!
There we go.
That's fine.
Oh!
Oh no.
You scared?
Yes!
Okay.
I do one more heals just in case.
Let's make this flashy.
Oh.
First try.
Jesus Christ.
That one was so hard.
I can't believe I first tried that That one was the hard
That one was not the hardest that one's Oh my god Oh my god
we did it It's just 2v1 It's just a 2v1 scenario There's
nothing to worry about You two keep training in hell I'll
end up down there sooner or later Nothing to worry about
guys It's okay.
Masashi, Shizuka!
Takamura is calling for you.
Come back quick!
What's going on?
I feel an ominous presence from the west.
It's almost as if...
As if what?
Like what?
I'm so tight!
Aratiyama has fallen.
No!
You mean it's overrun with malice?
indeed impossible that should be impossible why is this
worse than every other place of malice is that like the core
yeah rushyama is protected by nature and should be nine
invincible and yet it fell in an instant the fact that they
had two both of them had two phases I'm glad got rid of I
think getting rid of the wind guy was definitely a lot
easier i'm glad i got like i'm glad i killed him first
because i think he was the more annoying one compared to the
two the lightning is easier to predict let's go and see what
we can do
musashi be careful this is not normal if you sense danger
retreat immediately
The incidents from Yasaka Shrine To Ken Ninja Temple Oh, we
did it We did it Yeah, we did it Sorry wife, I'm gonna have
to Ignore you for a little bit I gotta upgrade some shove I
haven't
Yeah, we'll grab that Just so I can, like, pick it up
stronger Alright, I guess we can upgrade Isan I finally
doing it guys I guess um how much more of this game do we
have dragons is this the last area is this the last area
guys okay how long is this area very close how many hours do
you think take me before final dungeon okay then i'm gonna
call it here if this is like if there's still two this and
then the final dungeon i'm gonna call it here and then we'll
finish uh we'll finish the this game on the next place like
i said today it's not gonna be a long stream um i just need
to reset myself today but um i hope you guys had a fun time
watching i mean i did just one v2 two times today uh yeah we
did i did one v2 not just once but twice yeah and also have
a uh 2 a.m mean and greet for myself uh so but of course i
always had a fun time streaming for you guys i hope you guys
have fun time watching um next stream uh we will actually
finally finish Onimusha.
And also thank you to all the people who were at the Vexpo
concert and were able to watch the concert and also come
here and to hang out with me too.
I hope you guys enjoyed my set list with Duby and like I
said, Director's Cup will be uploaded on the channel later.
And our members, if you remembered, I will be posting the, I
will be posting the behind the scenes videos like the
choreograph, choreograph videos of the dances and stuff.
everything how the dances went uh any guys as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
get that blood flowing and if you except for me head to bed
cause you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
uh bye guys bye